okay so how you doing I'm doing great
you know just um she's doing what needs
to be done what does that mean I'm sorry
dad um why don't we just have lunch and
talk we can do that right please you
think that you have this under control I
understand why I do things it doesn't
make me any different you're just
embarrassed because I was like you know
I was like this amazing thing like your
special creation or something and you
know like Who I am now yeah who are you
Nick this is me dad here this is who I
am this is not you this is not you Nick
what are you doing huh you always gotta
be controlling everything all the time
let me let me [ __ ] hearing about at a
hotel for a couple of nights I want it
to go like this
[Music]
my son has gone missing Nicholas chef sh
e FF there's no one by that name sir
there are moments that I look at him
this kid that I raised who I thought I
knew inside and out
and I wonder who we is I thought we were
close I thought we were closer than most
fathers and sons why I felt bad so I
just kept doing it
this isn't us this is not who we are my
son is out there somewhere and I don't
know what he's doing I don't know how to
help him
you can't I don't feel like I have a
disease this isn't like cancer this is
my choice I put myself here I failed I
can't do it alone I need to find a way
to fill this black hole in me
I stole them the family I want to be
proud of me
what you have you're gonna find it again
you're gonna get it back do you know how
much I love you I love you more than
everything I love risking everything
everything
you